30 euros c'est ça aussi
au début c'était c'était une fois par
mois une fois tous les deux mois et puis
après
ça devient de plus en plus souvent et
puis voilà quoi et après quand quand la
famille la prenne bah
on se donne des fausses raisons il
arrive c'est comme ils sont au courant
sur comment j'y vais et puis je découche
et puis tant pis ils le savent et après
quand elle est possible de savent c'est
autre chose c'est
si j'ai envie de prendre une douche
c'est à peine si j'ai envie de me
changer c'est à peine si je pense que ça
je fais la manche je baratine
et je demande déjà de l'argent pour leur
dire que j'ai faim et on leur a été
c'est juste pour ça
moi j'ai volé mon père ma mère mes
frères mes sœurs je voulais tout le
monde mais mes gosses
à partir du moment où ils ont pris leur
dose de crack il se maîtrise plus et ça
hurle il y a beaucoup de bagarres entre
eux en fait et c'est des hurlements
toute la nuit jusqu'à au moins 4-5
heures du matin
tous les jours les commerçants on va
parler côté commerçants sont peuvent
être
volés peuvent avoir en fait des
problèmes si vous voulez à cause de ce
crack parce que les gens vont arriver
avec une agressivité vers les clients et
donc pour chercher en fait si vous
voulez un peu d'argent pour pouvoir
acheter la dose de crack
pour ouvrir le matin il faut on a
préconisé au nom des associations qui
qui s'intéressent et qui travaillent
avec ces populations là depuis des
années c'est l'ouverture de plusieurs
espaces de 6 espaces de repos où il
pourrait y avoir de la consommation
c'est pas un CAP de laisser aller c'est
un CAP de responsabilité et pragmatisme
si les Suisses l'ont fait c'est les
Canadiens l'ont fait c'est les Allemands
l'ont fait c'est les espagnols l'ont
fait c'est des dizaines de pays ils
l'ont fait s'il y a 100 actuellement
plus de sacs de consommation plus de 100
salles de consommation en Europe c'est
parce que ça marche
ok
l'idée n'est pas juste de les repousser
ou de la vie du 19e pour amener la
problématique sur un autre
arrondissement mais bien d'avoir une vue
globale et de faire un travail global de
prise en charge de tous ces toxicoman
sur la voie publique l'idée c'est
vraiment d'apaiser la voix publique avec
une présence policière renforcée
évidemment au-delà de la simple présence
mais qui déjà rassure et qui déjà évite
des rassemblements trop nombreux c'est
aussi évidemment de procéder à des
interpellations de Deezer